as the villains rise the there's an arms
race and the good guys have to increase
their force as well and I think there'll
be new heroes introduced on the good
guys side and they'll have to band
together and fight the rise of the
villains
hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my first Gotham season to preview
they were talking a lot about what was
going on who they're bringing on at
comic-con they just cast Michael Chiklis
as the new police detective so there's a
whole bunch of people to talk about
Bruno Heller was billing season 2 as the
rise of the villains and as a result of
that Gotham would need new heroes so I
think Chiklis is one of the new heroes
that he was talking about but it's just
a continued escalation like we saw in
the Dark Knight trilogy whereby batman
cleans out all the mob so that the real
freaks come out so batman has to up his
game we're gonna be seeing a form of
that happening on the show so plenty
more comic book villains on the way here
here are the ones that we've heard about
so far in addition to the ones that they
already established in season one that
didn't die there's Clayface Mad Hatter
tigress mr. freeze or Victor freeze
however you want to think about him and
they said there have been
behind-the-scenes discussions about
doing the court of owls but they didn't
say they're doing court of owls on top
of that they made some changes behind
the scenes with the the season 1 cast
two-face and Leslie Thompkins will be
cast regulars so we'll see both of them
all season long and there's going to be
a season long Joker arc with Cameron
Monaghan he was actually one of the few
Gotham villains that they brought to
comic-con even though he was just there
to do a bit what about Barbara - they
said that she will definitely not get
less crazy so I think they're just
pushing her in an arkham direction she's
not gonna be Harley Quinn but that's
kind of the picture I have in my head I
feel like her character would rook
really well if she got to be batshit
crazy all the time just because I didn't
think normal Barbara was all that
interesting she didn't have much of a
storyline either but most of my gripes
against Barbara were against her
storyline but we also have zazz coming
back and we'll probably see the
Scarecrow again at some point most of
the attention though is probably gonna
be given to these new characters that
they're trying to develop Batman has
like one of the best rogues galleries of
villains I think that owes a lot to the
fact that he had like a couple really
awesome villains so that made the
comment more popular which meant they
wrote more Batman which meant they ended
up writing more villains so it's like
this self-sustaining loop whereby you
know Batman props up all his villains so
they get to get really awesome character
development and his villains do the same
for him at other times like the more pop
character is the more they write
characters around that so it's just you
know the universe gets built out in much
deeper ways than comics that are less
popular overall I think the villain that
I'm most excited to see even if we don't
see him in like full-on comic-book
attire is Victor freeze just because mr.
freeze you know Arnold Schwarzenegger
notwithstanding is a really interesting
character I just I can't wait for him to
show up in an episode I can already feel
the Schwarzenegger puns washing over
Twitter just putting Gotham into context
with the other DC TV shows I feel like
last year Gotham was a little campy er
like it aired toward the sillier stuff
and this year I feel like it would
really benefit them to just lean into
the nightmare curve going like full-on
70s 80s nightmare Batman like when you
look at Kelly Jones Batman this is
actually this is what I was talking
about and I was actually wrong this is
actually early mid-90s just a full-blown
nightmare obviously we're not gonna see
Batman anytime soon but the the dark
Avenger of Gotham looks like it's gonna
be Michael Chiklis so hopefully he will
be equally as terrifying as some of the
villains but you know personally I would
rather see scary villains then like that
the slightly sillier ones that we saw at
various points like there's funny
Riddler and then there's scary stabby
Riddler I feel like Gotham needs to get
darker and scarier that I mean that's
just where Batman energy flows from to
give you a good idea like the complete
opposite of that spectrum look at the
Supergirl on CBS they're billing her is
like a really strong role model for
young girls so I think that just frees
up a lot of territory like in the the TV
landscape forgot them to be the most
amazing nightmare possible just
something that's so hypnotic and crazy
that you you can't look away but it just
it drives you mad make no mistake though
this is network television so it's not
gonna be like Netflix crazy levels of
violence or anything like that but I
feel like they can still capture like a
lot of the really dark energy from the
classic animated series like that did
dark Batman so well and it was a
children's cartoon speaking of
cartoonish we do know that fish Mooney
is dead Jada Pinkett Smith was like I've
only been contracted for one season so
if she appears it'll only be in
reference it'll be the penguin or some
other character remembering her I feel
like her character on Gotham was the
exact same character that she played in
Magic Mike XXL
and it fit way better in that Magic Mike
universe if Channing Tatum ever decides
to do
man XXL I feel like that fish mooney
character would be perfect for it that
says you could really jumping off point
for keep it or kill it so what is like
the favorite thing from season one that
you want to see comeback and what is the
one thing that you never want to see
again I feel like the one thing that a
lot of people never want to see again
is another Batman origin story Marvel is
getting ready to introduce a new
spider-man they're not doing another
origin story it's like we've seen it so
many times everybody gets it Uncle Ben
died we understand great power great
responsibility I feel like Batman is
next but there is actually like a
flashback scene in Batman V Superman but
it was in the trailer so it might not
end up being in the final cut of the
film just because there are always
scenes in trailers that they just cut
exclusively for the trailer speaking of
which I know a lot of you guys are
asking me about the fan theory that
Jared Leto's Joker and Suicide Squad is
really Jason Todd it looks like based on
the Batman V Superman footage that
they're doing the death in the family
it's like post death in the family
a Robin died it drove Batman to this
really dark place and it sounds like
Suicide Squad might actually be a
prequel to Batman V Superman so they
might address that I know a lot of
people were confused about who the Joker
had on the table in the Suicide Squad
trailer that's actually Harley Quinn
we'll probably see a Harley Quinn
flashback to the moment where the Joker
breaks her I don't know if the Jason
Todd theory is true but usually that's
something you would see in like a second
or third movie you wouldn't see
something like that spelled out
immediately but but I you know I can see
how they're trying to set up storylines
little little cross three or four movies
so whoever Jared Leto's Joker really is
I don't think that we'll find out till a
Suicide Squad sequel or like the first
solo Batman film it just feels like
there's like way too much stuff going on
in Batman V Superman already for them to
cram in Jason Todd stuff but if you guys
aren't familiar with the death in the
family arc it's a really dark actually
Jason Todd's mother really bad person
I'll put a link in the description I
talked about it during arrow season 3
but Gotham season two is gonna premiere
at the end of September just like last
year it'll be a Monday night 8 p.m. show
it'll it'll be like the only Monday show
I do for a little while Supergirl
doesn't start till November so Gotham
videos will get first priority be sure
to subscribe to get everything if
there's any like specific Gotham or
Batman Batman vs Superman or so
Suicide Squad videos you guys want just
just let me know in the comments there's
so much Batman stuff happening this fall
now that I'm through most of the Comic
Con news I'm gonna start working on
character videos for like the new comic
book characters that they announced so
while you guys wait for that stuff you
can click here for the Batman V Superman
trailer if you haven't seen that ant you
can click here to learn all about the
flash season 2 thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you